hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions consider a
number line that goes from zero to ten a
ball is on the line and starts at
position X is equal to one meter the
velocity of the ball is the same as its
x position so at X is equal to five
point two three four meters its velocity
would be five point two three four
meters per second how long would it take
for the ball to reach X is equal to ten
meters
I think Khan and fatigue Willi Pinar for
suggesting this problem can you figure
it out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
a solution
so how can we solve this problem well
it's an example of a separable
differential equation the balls velocity
at time T equals its position at T
translated into the language of
differential equations we have the balls
velocity which is DX DT is equal to its
position X now this is called separable
because we can separate the X terms on
one side and the T terms on the other so
we have DX over X is equal to DT we can
now integrate both sides of this
equation and we get that the natural log
of the absolute value of x is equal to T
plus an arbitrary constant we group all
the constants on the right hand side now
we'll solve for the constant we have the
initial condition that when the ball
starts out at T is equal to zero its
position X is equal to 1 so we
substitute in those values and we can
solve that C is equal to 0 so we have
the natural log of the absolute value of
X is equal to T and that'll be the
equation that we'll use to solve this
problem what is the time when X is equal
to 10 well we substitute in X is equal
to 10 and it's time will be the natural
log of 10 which is approximately 2.3
seconds and that's our answer did you
figure it out thanks for watching this
video these math videos which can be
watched for free on YouTube inspire and
build confidence for people around the
world and they already have over a 100
million views please subscribe for free
to get the newest videos and email me a
puzzle or mat topic presh and mind your
decisions calm if you so choose you can
check out my merchandise like mugs and
t-shirts at teespring you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support